اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
الحكومه الاسرائيليه توافق على انشاء
الحرس الوطني والمعارضه تصف الموافقه
بتمويل ميليشيات خاصه
طهران تتوعد بالرد على مقتل ضابطين في
الحرس الثوري بغاره جويه اسرائيليه على
سوريا
نيويورك تتحضر امنيا لمحاكمه ترامب
واستطلاعات جمهوريين تظهر تقدمه على
ديسنتوس
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
افادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بان مجلس
الوزراء وافق على انشاء الحرس الوطني تحت
قياده وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن جفير
واوضحت المصادر الاسرائيليه ان وزراء
بالحكومه اعربوا عن رفضهم لتشكيل الحرس
الوطني لكن صوتوا لصالحه في نهايه الامر
ومن المقرر ان يتم اقتطاء واحد فاصل خمسه
بالمئه من الوزارات اي 300 مليون دولار
وهو مبلغ التمويل السنوي للحرس الوطني
هذا الحرس الوطني سيكون موازيا للجيش
والشرطه الاسرائيليه
وسيتكون من مجموعه من الفرق الخاصه
للسيطره على اماكن حساسه يصعب على الشرطه
والجيش السيطره عليها
الحرس الوطني سيضم جنودا سابقين
وسيتم تدريبهم لتشكيل فرق تفرض سيطرتها
على الشارع اضافه الى تعديل بعض القوانين
وحل بعض المشاكل الداخليه في اسرائيل وقد
اشارت صحف اسرائيليه الى ان تكلفه انشاء
الحرس الوطني ستكون ضمن ميزانيه وزاره
الامن القومي التي حصل عليها اتمار لعمي
عشرين 23 وعشرين اربعه وعشرين بمبلغ تسعه
مليارات شيكل اي ما يعادل 2.5 مليون دولار
امريكي
هذا واتهم زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا
اير لبيد اتهم حكومه نتنياهو بالدهس على
الديمقراطيه وذلك لتنفيذ تخيلات اشخاص
متطرفين مهووسين كما جاء في بيانه وقال
لبيد ان حكومه نتنياهو وافقت على تمويل
ميليشيا خاصه
موضحا ان الحكومه ستقتطعوا من ميزانيه
الامن والتعليم والصحه لتمويل هذه
الميليشيات
وفي السياق ذاته اصر رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي على التدخل في ازمه خطه تغيير
النظام القضائي وذلك لانها تؤثر على امن
واقتصاد البلاد حسب تعبيره قائلا ان
العقلاء يفهمون ان الازمه الوطنيه لها
عواقب داخليه وخارجيه على دوله اسرائيل
وان رئيس الوزراء ملزم بالعمل لمصلحه
الشعب لمحاوله تحقيق اجماع وطني واسع وذلك
لمنع العنف وضمان القانون والنظام اليومي
للدوله اضافه الى امنها واستقرارها
الاقتصادي والحفاظ على العلاقات الخارجيه
للدوله
لمزيد من المتابعه اذهب الى القدس الان
ينضم اليه من هناك مراسل العربيه زياد حلب
زياد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المواقف
والتصريحات ازاءه موافقه حكومه نتنياهو
على انشاء ما يسمى بالحرس الوطني وهل ما
جرى زياد سيزيد من تازم المشهد الاسرائيلي
السياسي اكثر مما هو متازم الان
ابدا من حيث انتهيت بدون هذه الخطوه ستزيد
الطينه بله فيما يتعلق بالازمه الداخليه
في اسرائيل
اللافته في الامر بان المعارضه هذا
الموضوع ليست حكرا على المعارضه
الاسرائيليه ابدا وانما تمتد ايضا الى
مفوض عام الشرطه الاسرائيليه المستشاره
القضائيه
للحكومه رئيس جهاز المخابرات العامه
الشباب والرؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه ككل في
اسرائيل كلهم يعرضون بشده اقامه هذه
الميليشيا الخاصه من خارج اطار الشرطه
الاسرائيليه لان ذلك قد يعتبر انعدام
الثقه بالمؤسسه الامنيه من جهه وقد يعقد
الاداء على الارض عمليا بعمل موازن يعتمر
باوامر وزير مثل بن جفير عمليا يلفتون في
اسرائيل في صفوف المعارضه على الاقل الى
ان الرجل ليس فقط ليس لديه اي تجربه امنيه
ساب لم يخدم يوما في الجيش الاسرائيلي بل
هو مدان في محكمه اسرائيليه بالارهاب
وعمليا هناك عشرات الشكاوى ضده جنائيا
لانه اعتدى على فلسطينيين وعلى رجال شرطه
وبالتالي هذا الامر يبدو
مستغربا جدا لكن دعنا فقط نشير الى ان
ربما الامر ليس بهذه الدقه لم تقرر
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليوم اقامه هذه
الميليشيا او هذا الجسم الامني وانما ما
قامت به هو اقرار التمويل فقط
اقامت لجنه على هذه اللجنه ان تعود لاحقا
بتوصياتها للحكومه الحكومه عمليا لم تطلق
بعد هذا الموضوع بس زياد حتى لو كانت
المساله مجرد اقرار موضوع التمويل لما
يسمى بالحرس الوطني
يبدو وكان طلبات بني غفير يستجاب لها برغم
الحديث العناني من بعض الوزراء عن
معارضتهم
لهذا المشروع ولكن يعني في العلن شيء
ووراء الابواب المغلقه شيء اخر اليس كذلك
صحيح جدا وهذا يؤكد ربما ما ذهبنا اليه
منذ تشكيل هذه الحكومه بان نتنياهو بات
اسيرا بيد الوزراء الاكثر تطرفا مثل بين
جفير وسمودريتش والبينه على ذلك بانه حتى
يعلق التعديلات
القضائيه عمليا اضطر الى الموافقه خلال
دقائق على طلب الذي استغل الفرصه وابتز
نتنياهو وطلب ان يبدا خطوه عمليه ماء على
صعيد تشكيل هذه الميليشيا او هذا الجسم
الامني خارج اطار الشرطه الاسرائيليه بهذا
المعنى نتنياهو يبدو ضعيفا ليس في
استطلاعات الراي فقط في اسرائيل وانما
فعليا داخل الحكومه ايضا طيب بالنسبه الى
المعارضه ماذا تملك بعد من اوراق غير
الشارع واذا عدنا للشارع هل نتوقع في
الايام المقبله تظاهرات بمئات الالوف اذا
ما يجري ام لا الامور يعني عم نشوف انه في
ضبابيه بالمشهد كثير زياده
الشارع هو من يقود المعارضه وليس العكس
بمعنى ولان لهذا لان الشارع لا يتالف من
المعارضه التقليديه اي لا نقصد المعارضه
هنا في الكنيست ليست هذه من في الشارع من
في الشارع هم خليط من اليمين واليسار ومن
النخب العسكريه والسياسيه والاكاديميه
والاجتماعيه في اسرائيل لهذا يستطيعون
دائما تحريك مئات الالاف كما رايت يوم
السبت الماضي بالامس عمليا ليلا كان هناك
مئات الالاف تظاهروا في مختلف المناطق
منهم 180 الفا في تل ابيب وحدها هذا ستراه
اتباعا على اساس اسبوعي وقد يكون هناك
تصعيد ايضا كما كان لان عمليا الاعتقاد
لدى المعارضين بان المفاوضات لدى الرئيس
الاسرائيلي ولدت ميته لا احد يثق حقا
من القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي دائما
شكرا لك زياده على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
الى شان اخر فقد تواعدت الخارجيه
الايرانيه اسرائيل بالرد في الزمان
والمكان المناسبين بعد اعلان الحرس الثوري
الايراني مقتل ضابط ثاني برتبه نقيب خلاله
هجوم تتهم طهران اسرائيل بشنه في سوريا
فجر يوم الجمعه الماضي
بدون انظمه التي تدعم الارهاب خارج حدود
اسرائيل ثمنا باهظا اقترح على اعدائنا الا
يخطئوا الجدول الداخلي في اسرائيل لا يضر
ولن يضر بتصميمنا او شدتنا او قدرتنا على
العمل ضد اعدائنا في جميع الجبهات وفي اي
مكان وفي اي وقت
على صعيد اخر نقلت وكاله تسنيم عن البحريه
الايرانيه قولها بانها ابعد الطائره تجسس
امريكيه من طراز لوكيد لوكيد اي بي ثري
انتهكت المجال الجوي للبلاد بالقرب من
خليج عمر واوضحت البحريه الايرانيه ان
الطائره الامريكيه بعد تلقيها الرسائل
التحذيريه غادرت المجال الجوي الايراني
وعادت الى الاجواء الدوليه
[موسيقى]
طبعا هذه الاخبار العاجله من وزاره الطاقه
السعوديه مصدر في وزاره الطاقه السعوديه
يؤكد ان التخفيض الطوعي جاء بالتنسيق مع
دول في منظمه اوبك وخارجها اذا تخفيض في
انتاج النفط السعودي ابتداء من مايو
المقبل حاله من التاهب تشهدها نيويورك قبل
مثول الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
امام المحكمه الثلاثاء بالتهمم المرتبطه
بدفع 130 الف دولار لممثله الافلام
الاباحيه ستورميدانيلز لشراء صمتها
المساله تثير راي العام الامريكي بشده
ماذا دفع شرطه نيويورك للتاهب ووضع كلي
عناصرها في حاله انتشار بلباسهم الرسمي
على الطرق العامه لمده اسبوع حسب مصادر
شبكه ام بي سي
ومن جهته كشف المتحدث باسم شرطه نيويورك
في تصريحات صحفيه ان تاهب الشرطه ياتي
للرد على اي تجاوزات قد تحدث وذلك لضمان
سير حياه الناس بشكل طبيعي
[تصفيق]
اذا نذكر بالخبر العاجل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تعلن تخفيضا طوعيا في انتاج
النفط بمقدار نصف مليون برميل يوميا
ابتداء من
المقبل هذا وقد سئل الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عن تاثير توجيه لائحه اتهامات
لمنافسه السياسي فرد بالقول لا تعليق ولن
اتحدث عن الاتهامات ضد ترامب
سياسه عدم التعليق والصمت المتعمد من قبل
بايدن وفريقه لها ابعاد استراتيجيه وفق
محللين ديمقراطيين لوكاله
هذه الاستراتيجيه من قبل البيت الابيض
كانت تتبع مع رئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
على مدى عامين وهي ان الصمت من ذهب
ومسؤولوها البيت الابيض يخططون الاتباع
قواعد اللعبه نفسها في الوقت الحالي وبحسب
الخبيره الاستراتيجيه الديمقراطيه يجب على
اداره بايدن الاستمرار في فعل ما فعلته
طوال الوقت مع التركيز على الحكم ومعالجه
مخاوف الامريكيين
وعلى الرغم من ان الانتخابات التمهيديه
للجمهوريين ما تزال بعيده لكن المعركه من
اجل نيل ترشيح الحزب لقوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ما زالت على زخمها بين الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ومنافسه حيث اظهرت
استطلاعات للراي نشرها موقع ذهل تقدم
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للجمهوريه بواقع
احدى وثلاثين نقطه اي بنسبه 52% من
الاصوات فيما جاء ديسانتس في المرتبه
الثانيه بنسبه 21%
اذن الاخبار العاجله وزير النفط الكويتي
الان يعلن تخفيضا طوعيا في انتاج النفط
بمقدار 128 الف برميل يوميا كانت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تحدثت ايضا عن خفض في
موضوع النفط سيبدا من مايو وينتهي بنهايه
20 23
والتخفيض الطوعي لانتاج النفط سيكون
بمقدار نصف مليون برميل يوميا بدايه مما
مايو هذا من جانب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من الكويت
الخفض سيكون بمقدار
128 الف برميل يوميا اذا سنتابع هذه
الاخبار وهذه العواجل التي تريدنا فيما خص
موضوع خفض انتاج النفط من عدد من دول اوبك
على كل نشرتنا مستمره وفي ايضا
ومبكرا في اسبانيا
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه اعود
فاذكر بالاخبار العاجله فقد اعلنت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه منذ قليل تخفيضا طوعيا
في انتاج النفط بمقدار نصف مليون برميل
يوميا ابتداء من مايو المقبل واوضح مصدر
في وزاره الطاقه السعوديه ان التخفيض
الطوعي سيبدا من مايو وينتهي بنهايه العام
الحالي واكد المصدر ان التخفيض الطوعي جاء
بالتنسيق مع دول من منظمه اوبك ومن خارجها
مشيرا الى ان التخفيض الطوعي هو اجراء
احترازي يهدف لدعم استقرار اسواق النفط
بالطبع منذ قليل سلطنه عمان تعلنوا ايضا
تخفيضا طوعيا في انتاج النفط بمقدار 40
الف برميل يوميا هذا الموقف الان من سلطنه
عمان العراق ايضا يعلن تخفيضا طوعيا في
انتاج النفط بمقدار
2001 عشر الف برميل يوميا ايضا كان وزير
النفط الكويتي قد اعلن عن تخفيض طوعي في
انتاج النفط بمقدار
128 الف برميل يوميا اما وزير الطاقه
الاماراتي فاعلن عن تخفيض طوعي في انتاج
النفط بمقدار
144 الف برميل يوميا
اشاد الرئيس الاوكراني
بصد الجيش الاوكراني لما وصفه باكبر قوه
معاديه للانسانيه في الذكرى الاولى للعثور
على جثث مدنيين اوكرانيين في مدينه بوتشا
خلال السيطره الروسيه على المدينه وقد
قدرت اكياف عدد القتلى المدنيين بحوالي
1400 شخص قتلوا في مدينه بوتشا العام
الماضي
مجددا الى الزميل هاني صفيان مراسل
العربيه هو معي من داخل الحرم المكي هاني
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد جديد المشهد من
عندك وابرز مشاهداتك
نعم كما تحدثت قبل قليل طالب ان هناك اكثر
من تسعه مليون ونصف المليون معتمد وزاري
استفادوا من الخدمات التي تقدمها رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين وان ايضا في من اول ايام
رمضان حتى الان بلغ عدد المعتمرين هذا
الرقم طبعا ايضا من ضمن الخدمات التي
تقدمها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين هي
خدمات
لصحه وسلامه ايضا المعتمرين منها هذا
المختبر الذي يعد الاول من نواعي على
مستوى العالم والذي يفحص مياه زمزم وكذلك
التمور وقت الافطار التي تدخل الحرام
عموما بشكل سريع سوف ينضم معي الاستاذ حسن
السويري وهو مدير اداره الوقايه هنا في
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين مرحبا بك كيف يتم
عمليه فحص مياه زمزم وكذلك المواد
الغذائيه او التمور تحديدا وقت الافطار
للمعتمرين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هنا في مختبر الحرم هذا المختبر الذي يهتم
بفحص مياه زمزم
وقياس
الكلور والمعق اللي تستخدم لتقييم مال
زمزم ايضا هنا المختبر يسن فحص التمور
وعينات التمور وتستخدم في الافطار المدار
العام وايضا هنا بالاخص الان في شهر رمضان
المبارك انت يتم عمليه فحص احدى العينات
مياه زمزم نتكلم عن التقنيات التي
استخدامها يتم استخدامها الان وما هو
الفرق بين مياه زمزم والمياه المعدنيه
الاخرى او المياه زينب اولا هي لا يتم
تعقيمها او تصفيتها هي مياه ربانيه من
البئر تخرج هكذا ويتم فحص العينات من
الناحيه الاحياء الدقيقه وايضا نحيى من
الناحيه الكلور من ناحيه
النقاط زمزم تخرج من البير من هنا الى كدي
تن فحصها ويتم
تعقيمها بشعه بنفسجيه وتجي الى الحرم عبر
اربع نقاط خلال هذه النقاط مع المضخات قد
يكون فيها شوائب قد يكون فيها اي شائبه
يتم فحص التاكد من سلامتها ب 250 عائله
يوميا تفحص حرام شكرا لك يا استاذ حسن اذا
250 عينه تفحص هنا من مياه زمزم
شكرا جزيلا لك لضيق الوقت سنكون معك في
نشرات لاحقه بطبيعه الحال يعطيك الف عافيه
انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[موسيقى]